(audience applauding and cheering)
Oh man.
Hello.
Thanks so much for coming.
Nah, thanks for having me.
It's like 11, what is it, 24 hours ago
I think I found out I was
going to be or something.
Oh, that's cool.
Yeah.
It was nice of you to
come by and help us out.
Exactly, I should have
brought my good razor.
(audience laughing)
(laughs) You could have helped us out.
It would have gone a little faster.
[Macaulay] Exactly.
I think you'd look good if
half your head was shaved.
What do you think, crowd?
That's what everyone's saying backstage.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
No, no, no, that's all right.
You know, I want to ask you something.
Actually we've worked
together a little bit
outside of this project
here at the Late Night show.
And I never got to ask you this before
and it must be annoying, but
you must still get people
that even though you've
achieved a lot of great things
acting as an adult, you
must still get people
that can't let go of
the "Home Alone" thing
and come up to you and ask
for the "Home Alone" face.
Yeah, no, I get it a good amount.
And I just basically say to
them, "You know what, it's sad.
"You don't want to see it."
(Conan laughing)
It'd be like, it's really
pathetic, he's old.
You know, what happened, you know?
Right, right, right, right.
So yeah.
No, that's the good--
Yeah, exactly so.
People that are like, what do you expect?
Like, you'll be doing
that in clubs going around
doing that, it's like...
Exactly.
Give people the wrong impression, exactly.
You actually still have a
scar on you, I've been told,
that you got from Joe Pesci
shooting "Home Alone."
Is that true?
Yeah.
It's on my finger, yeah.
It's actually one of the scenes, you know,
they hang me up on the
closet door or something.
They said, "I'm gonna bite
each one of your fingers off
"one at a time" and during
rehearsal he actually bit me.
(audience laughing)
And it broke the skin and everything.
I'm a little nine-year-old boy
and he's going around
biting 'em, you know?
And I still have the scar.
I didn't even realize it until recently
and there it is, the little thing.
Now, did you get mad
when Joe Pesci bit you?
Yes, I did, I got really mad at him.
I was like, I don't care
how many Oscars you have
or whatever, like, don't.
Biting a nine year old, what
the heck's wrong with you?
I love the idea of you just blowing up
on the set of that movie.
Yeah, it was like, hey.
Well also, they hang me up on a door
so I'm also hanging on
a door at the same time
so I'm like, "What are you doing?"
(Conan and audience laughing)
Probably not the most threatening
you've ever been in your life.
Yeah, yeah, "Who do you think you are?"
Kicking your legs, "I'll get you!"
(audience laughing)
There's a dark side I wanna explore.
You've hung out some with Marilyn Manson.
Yes, yeah.
Let's talk about that of course.
He was in "Party Monster" with me.
Yeah, and his character smoked in it
so he kind of wanted to learn
how to smoke and so he--
Marilyn Manson didn't know how to smoke?
He didn't know how to smoke.
Never smoked a day in his life, he said.
You know, the king, the
antichrist, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
He didn't know how to smoke.
He's like, well, it's not healthy.
(audience laughing)
Exactly.
Praise the devil.
Want a cigarette?
No, it's not healthy.
(audience cheering and applauding)
So you know, he had this
very specific vision
of what kind of cigarettes
he wanted in his mind.
So he wanted me, the avid
smoker to go with him
and help him out and
so we go to the store.
Basically, he wanted Virginia
Slims 100's basically.
And so that was what he
wanted so we got him--
Virginia Slims?
Virginia Slim 100's.
Isn't that kind of an old lady cigarette?
Exactly, but it was
what he saw in his head
so I said, "Okay, cool."
And I just remember we were
walking out of the store.
I mean, it's like, he's six
foot five and I'm, you know,
five foot (mumbles) and so
(audience laughing)
yeah, I just remember he turned to me.
It was just this weird silence.
He goes, "You know, that's
a Conan O'Brien story."
He was like, "You gotta make sure
you tell that on Conan O'Brien"
that I was corrupting the
antichrist, so, you know.
I love that Macaulay Culkin
is convincing, you know,
Marilyn Manson to have a cigarette.
Exactly, go ahead, it's fine.
(audience laughing)
What's happened?
Now, let's talk about this movie "Saved!"
"Saved!"
This is an interesting idea.
It takes place at a Christian high school.
Yeah, kind of a Christian high school
set in this kind of modern Christian town.
And it's kind of just, I don't know,
it's a fun, funny kind of dark comedy.
Right, right, it's--
With a fantastic ensemble.
How did you prepare for this movie?
Did you hang out at all
with Christian groups?
Yeah, we went to a bunch of youth rallies
and Christian rock concerts.
And we went to this big one at,
I think it's Edison Field in Anaheim
where the Angels play and it's, you know,
it was like the U2 soundalike rock band
or the Radiohead soundalike rock band.
They're all Christian rock bands.
They sound like those bands,
but then they just throw in stuff
about the loaves and the fishes.
Exactly, it's kind of
uplifting, exactly, you know.
And 40,000 born-again Christians
who are all blond, by the way.
Just this sea of blond
born-again Christians.
And I just remember
walking out of that place
and it was just weird 'cause
there was people picketing
and they were passing out all
these leaflets like, you know,
don't got to this, it's terrible
and it was other Christians.
These other Christians were
picketing these other Christians
and they picketing each other.
And they were mad
that these Christians were
enjoying some rock music
that even had a Christian theme?
Exactly, exactly.
That seems odd.
So I just thought it was
weird that, you know,
the Christians are picketing each other.
I think we can get away
with doing a dark comedy
about them, you know?
Right.
But we'll see.
I mean, I think a good amount
of the Christian community
has actually kind of
responded to the movie
which is very good, very good to see.
Did you get recognized at
the big Christian rock show?
Yes, that was funny, you know,
'cause it wasn't that
normal like, oh, do the face
or, you know, it was this kind of like,
"We're so glad you're here!"
You know, they really
thought like, you know.
(audience laughing)
I didn't want to break
their hearts and like,
yeah, I'm just here for
research or something, you know?
But it was just this, it was amazing.
They were just so happy
to see me there, you know?
Just like, they thought I
was one of them. (chuckles)
Right, right.
(audience laughing)
You sneaky bastard.
That's me.